a lot of las vegas shows on pause many
performers are turning to the las vegas
circus center to help keep their skills
in tune
jc is live with the details on the
classes they offer for all
levels hey jc
lindsay first off welcome back it's
great to hear your voice and i'm
bringing the circus to you today this is
going to be so much fun
this is brandt he's the owner of it brad
what inspired you to open up a circus
training center in las vegas my wife and
i have four kids we moved here to vegas
about 18 years ago
and we have four kids that are circus
enthusiasts
we've seen the benefits that training
circus arts have to do with kids
building self-esteem
just making people confident and like
abilities as well as it's a great
physical fitness
now this is open to anyone so think
about your kids are at home doing zoom
classes all day cases
they can come down here and train circus
style let's get a shot of some stuff
that's taking place right now
because i'm actually getting up on the
trapeze i was practicing that's why i'm
winded but what are we looking at down
here
we're looking at some artists uh
practicing a russian swing
one of the more dangerous aspects we
don't this wouldn't be a kids program
but we do have aerial arts over here to
the left over here on the floor but this
is uh
this is a russian swing this might be
featured in shows such as cirque du
soleil
some of the dragon shows house of
dancing water et cetera
we have a sear wheel over here we do
have kids cereal programs you can see
one of our coaches there uh actually
practicing and filming some stuff now
the great thing a lot of people we're
looking at right now are performers from
cirque shows there's no shows taking
place
and a lot of these people are trainers
uh a lot of your trainers are from surf
shows as well
yeah that's right this is like one of
the i mean one of the top facilities in
the world let's go to the chat house
so it's great we have such great artists
that
are trained here even when shows are in
session
a number of one of our a number of our
coaches are professional artists all
right we've got 1 30. brent take me all
over i'm going up i'm going up we're
going to the trapeze live
on las vegas now guys i'm coming up who
who are the trainers up there
the trainers are uh richard man
yeah coming down coming down safety
first you gotta get hooked in and here's
how funny the guys up there said the
scariest part of this thing is climbing
the ladder
so when you get me hooked in i got about
60 seconds here
okay you ready for me up there coming up
i gotta tell you i'm a little nervous
doing this i'm ready to climb up here we
go
yeah the people up on the board right
now are a family that's
been featured in a lot of cirque du
soleil shows such as
zed uh circus lay mystere
uh they're waiting for my steer to open
again so that people can see them
perform live
all right how are you good to see you
guys here we go
all right so i need some chalk from my
hands
they're unhooking me and hook me into
something else
45 seconds here chalk
i'm ready i'm a little bit nervous to be
honest i've never done a trapeze before
i'm all chalked up bran is this do i
look okay you look fantastic
and can anybody do these classes come
and take trapeze classes take this class
this is exactly right anybody can come
take these here we go
trying to please okay so what am i doing
okay
come on
fantastic yes sir
i noticed some hesitation entire time
back to you again you were good i didn't
know what i said leading up to that i
really don't this is a wonderful place
let's send it back to you guys
great man that was fun thank you jason
excellent job
there was a little hesitation there he
did say one two three go
and he's like now go now i would have
been the same way
oh my god that's fun all right we're
going to check back in with jc during
the 4 p.m newscast maybe he'll do a back
flip by then maybe hold on
he's going to be yeah he'll have
somebody jumping and catching him and
he's going to be all over